and i have believed in the principles
outlined in the law
but it is clear that section 230 in its
current form
is no longer working
just last week justice clarence thomas
said the courts have read
sweeping new protections into 230 that
congress
never put into statute
it is time to scrap the law and start
over
yesterday the new york post one of the
country's largest newspapers
published a piece on hunter biden and
his work on the board of ukrainian
energy company burisma which he had no
qualifications for it is an important
story as most americans would be
appalled by the vice president's son
using his father's position
to earn an enormous contract from
foreign companies
but the response from many in the media
and twitter and facebook
bring to light an even bigger concern
the biggest social networks are
selectively censoring information
if you are a citizen and posted
information in the story
your account was locked last night the
republican house judiciary committee
posted the story on their website a
government
website and this morning twitter has
censored it
did big tech censor the media and
americans when they posted about the
unverified and later debunked still
dossier did big tech censor the media
and americans when they posted about
trump's taxes
which were of course obtained illegally
did big tech censor the world's largest
sponsor of terrorism
the supreme leader of iran the answer to
all three questions is no
if social media companies intend to use
the protections provided by congress
for some americans but not for others we
should remove those special standards
all together now ranking member jim
jordan and the house judiciary committee
have legislation
that should be voted on to restore free
expression
in americans town squares
republicans are clear on what we need to
do to serve the american public
republicans are part of our commitment
to america have been clear how we would
restore our way of life
rebuild the economy and renew the
american dream
chief among our goals is keeping small
businesses open
and the employees on payroll i know what
it's like to have a dream
i know what it's like to have a dream to
have a small business
in fact we have been relentless in our
push to get speaker pelosi
to provide needed relief for americans
she continues to turn her back
and focus on politics not people 81 days
ago
when speaker pelosi was asked if the
house will stay in session
until a deal is negotiated she answered
we can't go home without it
a few days later she sent us home for
the august recess with no deal
republicans have attempted to bring up
small business committee ranking member
steve chabot's legislation
to reopen paycheck protection to support
small businesses
and their employees but democrats have
blocked
any ppp money going forward
39 times that's 39
times we brought it to the floor that
they have voted no on it
speaker pelosi does not want to lift a
finger to help the american people
because she believes in her own words
and let me quote
that nothing is better than something
and negotiations are all about leverage
it is clear she has offered resistance
instead of relief and she has wasted
precious time this year
eating ice cream in front of a
refrigerator blaming a salon owner for
her special treatment
and now insulting wolf blitzer these are
not
actions of a functioning democratic
majority
with that i'll take any questions
yes sir um the president keeps talking
about that he would like to see congress
go big or go home
on a coven relief bill i think the
administration's offer is somewhere
around 1.8 trillion right now he's
talked about going even higher than that
would house republicans support a 1.8
trillion or
bigger deal if that's reached between
the speaker and the white house
you know what's most interesting here is
the president 1.8 is a very big deal
a large that that's a big deal but
unfortunately nancy pelosi still makes
us go home
instead of getting something done i
think the american people would want
anything to have to go forward
republicans have time and again
pushed forwards ideas forward
unfortunately the speaker controls the
house
so the answer to your question it
doesn't matter what our answer would be
because the speaker has denied anything
for moving even her own
members to vote for a 1.8 trillion
dollar or you know i would always
i'd always read a bill before i
encourage anybody to vote for anything
but what's interesting to me is her
own members the democrats have asked her
to take this deal
she is the only hurdle the only
roadblock to us even being able to vote
on something
we have a discharge petition that would
remove ppp money that's sitting there
137 billion dollars
she has forced her members not to sign
there is one stumbling block to any deal
getting through
it doesn't matter the size the speaker
of the house is the only one that's
denying it
yes do you have any like what's your do
you believe that there will be a coveted
relief deal i know we keep asking this
question but will there be a covered
relief deal for the american people
before the election as long as speaker
pelosi is involved i think the answer is
easily no
you've watched her every single time
we've tried to have coveted relief she's
always held the process up
now she's strangling the american public
by denying anything moving
you watched even her arguing with wolf
blitzer
because he wanted to read quotes from
her own members
asking her to take the deal
i think she cares more about politics
than she cares about the american public
it's obvious
with her actions remember why she said
she doesn't want to go forward
she is fearful the american public would
get a check
fearful that the president would get
some credit instead of helping the
american public in this time of need
yes i just have a quick question
regarding um quota 19
if the deal if a deal is approved on a
bill goes to the center and your members
are
have to come back what is your plan to
keep your members and their staff safe
from the coronavirus
well that's a great question you'll know
about four or five months ago
i put a report out along with rodney
davis and tom cole on how we could keep
the house safe
one of that elements was testing
unfortunately speaker pelosi has denied
that
the protections on which committees we'd
bring back the size of staff in which
we'd bring back
unfortunately speaker pelosi has denied
all the abilities where we worked with a
lot of the medical community
to come with a plan to keep the house
safe one of those would be testing
thank you so very much have a good day
you